fun fact all the woman in my past are
what inspired Kyoto from the garage and
that's funny that's really that's great
this is gonna be really therapeutic for
you know she she always wins and haunts
them forever
well yeah I'm looking forward to the
grudge reboot great way to start off
January 2020 let's swing into this my
friends so a lot of reactions in the
past few days have been getting deep
monetizing this one got blocked
worldwide so there's a link in the
description box a Vimeo link of just the
trailer reaction in and of itself you
guys can go click that link watch your
reaction then come back to this video to
watch the review it's the only way we
could work around it so go ahead and do
that take a page out of the it chapter 2
trailer on the creepy old lady scene the
main female protagonist going to the
house visiting creepy old lady and then
scares them a bit of a montage except
it's booked in by the famous shower
moment gotta love that shower
you know what's got me excited about
this to some sort of degree lynch shake
oh yeah lin shaye said this she actually
had a lot of creative freedom with
getting involved in this movie being
able to do some scene work contribute
these ideas that the director normally
wouldn't take on but he was so inspired
by everything she was doing that she was
allowed to be part of the creative
process on this and this does feel
different I think does feel a bit like a
Sabu even more so at least did the brief
glimpses of the actual physical was like
you know people literally sawing things
often and her cutting her fingers up and
the police aspect of these rotting
bodies and stuff it's kind of I guess a
bit of a Saw movie me and I go
a little bit of like an insidious vibe
to it because I think jus one and the
grudge were made by the same director I
believe so yeah
so that definitely had more that natural
je horas that I could feel to it and
this feels a little bit more inspired by
ya instead of feeling like someone from
that country came over here and made one
you know and it has this like grimy
grainy color palette to its four loaf I
must especially and that just enhances
when she finds that body in the armchair
you could just smell it through the
screen there's some yeah I guess that's
true I feel some level of appreciation
for what we just saw at least for a
trailer weirdly curious and kind of
looking forward to it just cuz like at
least judging by these trailers does
looking intense and creepy and they got
like Andrea Riseborough like this she
throws herself into stuff I mean it
looks like just taking this really
seriously yeah I mean you got a whole
bunch of actors in here who look like
they're really committed to this doesn't
feel campy whatsoever now I guess the
question is it's like when we're
watching the actual film itself because
so far I think the paschal it's feathers
they match to cut something together
pretty neat the thing with the film
itself is like you can have all the
actors on board taking this seriously
you have a director who I think really
knows how to establish mood and tone I
guess when you're watching the movie
it's just are the sequences and the plot
and what the characters ultimately
decide to do is that going to be stupid
you know is that gonna be dumb Jane this
earth opening January weekend tends to
get me really nervous
it's The Grudge so I have these natural
hesitations towards it that like it
seems like everything on a technical
scale is fraught and I feel like
everyone's really committed to what's
going on there's just that that
suspicion
there's gonna be some dumb stuff in this
movie yeah it's not in the trailers I
can't say I've seen it in the trailers
and I'm like there's looks leaping from
the trailers hi there's just like weird
sneaking suspicion though of just
there's something I'm not be not seeing
but it's gonna be there you know yeah I
feel like maybe this either had the
release day makes me curious because
yeah these trailers have me pleasantly
intrigued but at the same time I feel
like yeah I gotta be that thing where
it's silly in a way it shouldn't be or
maybe just one of those movies that
isn't quite dynamic enough you know some
of those January releases you see where
you're like this isn't a bad movie it's
just you know kind of paste in a blocky
way or in a way that is you know kind of
longer than it even is you know movie
that feels longer than it actually is
yeah because it is a little over rodders
taking itself too seriously I can see it
kind of maybe falling into that trap too
or just trying to get to sequences yeah
yeah you have like these actors who are
taking it all really seriously but the
writing isn't supporting all that so you
know it can feel override like like yeah
that's what I worry about but I hope my
optimism says maybe they've realized how
much success these people are having you
know like blim house in january/february
so maybe they're just trying to corner
that market and the only bec you know
the only counter to that is I think
Sadako versus kayak Oh also came out
early in the year that's not real
well-regarded so yeah one remember they
do these montages they like my Anna
looks like the other grudge movies but
that sequence with Lin Shaye at the
beginning bring down at the very very
top of this trailer that felt the most
different yeah I felt like a yeah like a
whole other level of madness yeah yeah
you know that fits into the world but
isn't exactly isn't the shower scene
again alright guys well what do you
think of this new grudge movie are you
excited for what's to come
do you think this will reinvigorate the
franchise leave a comment down below you
can subscribe to the reel rejects please
click that notification bell to get
notified
never we got a YouTube video I've
notified know if I knew if I hit the
like butter in the dislike button either
one is okay with us you know one is
preferable whatever
last but not least I'll attendance with
a patron today shout out to a man named
Andrew Nickerson Andrew dude been a
while since I've heard from you man you
and I were having a great back and forth
for quite some time and then I noticed
that with a couple of ladies I was
bringing on kept shouting you out having
them say like flirtatious compliments to
you because I know you're a single guy
but I feel like for some reason that's
cause you to distance yourself from me
don't get self-conscious come on man
don't hold uh-oh the ring a guru tied
shudders died The Grudge - yes yeah
thank you welcome
I was looking for Joe on you on don't
hold a jewel that's what we got the day
huh girl - at you and thanks for being
for our patreon page